oh my god that is nasty what a
sick move bishop takes c2 takes b3
that was the point everybody is queen a1 mate
was threatened sorry robert guide no that was so
sick that was so sick here he's gotta convert and
then we'll back up and show that tactic but the uh
that was that was a very very nice finish there
oh and this is only 25 moves in and white's
just getting pummeled yeah you can even got
to take a2 first and then you're threading
to check on the c file this should just be
clean man what a shot with knight what is
happening here jack you take b2 it's over wow
now now parham's laughing he
might as well have just been like
like dude dude dude you couldn't
have let me get one dude
and now magnus is even demonstrating wow he's
demonstrating the corresponding squares of king
wait a second i'm not sure magnus should have done
that though yeah wait don't go too far wait oh
now they're just dancing like a couple of fools
right oh man parham is laughing because magnus
there voluntarily went into a pawn ending with
a pawn down but i gotta like white here as black
is congested and now the king to g7 interrupting
the play where's that king going i think he just
needed to make a move and here he goes queen
to c3 and queen c7 and now they're flying
i'm not sure anybody's winning here rook siete is
the king is on a six what rook c8 come on now this
is not real no way you're surviving this position
can you be queen c7 a trade i think they're just
blitzing now they're not sure what's happening
at all what's this oh my gosh here comes the king
this is good g4 is a bad move g4 was definitely
a bad move it did not it was not correct but you
know what right around now it doesn't matter
what correct is because they're just blitzing
two seconds left three seconds both sides just
go just going down with no time on the clock
it's winning for black though knight g3 knight
takes e4 he just win the pawn directly it's
a very good uh king walk oh it's a draw oh my
god it's some kind of a caspar of game you know
this guy's powerful yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah evergreen and stuff 12 seconds
you cannot defend this with black in this time
it's just for sure just somehow wins this game
what is he doing what is it why did he
allow the king back in king was like
i have no idea what's going on 36 seconds man 36
seconds he needs to just drag it out and not lose
oh he's actually losing control of the position
he's losing he's losing his queen and he's he's
in time he's also in time he doesn't does he
know yesterday oh my god oh my epic epic epic
this is brilliant this is insane
the players have to rematch let's go here we go
okay but this should be a hole three pawns through
he barely got that move off oh my god oh wait was
was there a win there a check and a trade on a7
oh oh my god he's just winning now what he trades
and wins the pawn and sauron is gonna be down
three games headed into bullet what a heartbreaker
to bring the five minute to a close let's
just take a quick peek at that like
you said this should have been a draw
even just back to this moment here but f3 which
is so heartbreaking it's the natural move to play
right f3 is like i've got my rook behind the
pawn for a reason here everybody let's dance
but f3 actually trades into the lost king and pawn
ending the pawn loses its protection and with it
sauron loses the game oh
wait the ropes trap itself
oh hey car laughs the car's laughing he's like
how did that happen he's like oops rook h4 g5
wow that looks so happy look at this
yeah that's an awkward move to miss
and now bishop f7 hikaru gives the nod of i
don't think so now you're allowing knight d5
yeah and knight f5 is getting out wait
knight f740 oh my gosh the car goes down
oh my gosh yeah the knight f6 queen takes f6 and
was that king upon any winnie
oh my god multiple wins missed because he
takes f2 as me wait what is happening here
who's gonna win queen d5 check and is
and blacks winning levon is up a pawn
check looks like uh oh wait what why did he do
this he blundered wesley blundered in one move
oh my god he just resigned that was unbelievable
he had two let's back up he had two and a half
minutes so wesley just just miscalculates i mean
he still could have just played 97 and sat tight
he's still totally winning but he just yes forgets
that the uh the rook and can take and i don't
have to do anything else for my back rank i'm
just winning the shade wow that is it turn around
what an extraordinary turnaround what really just
cut that rook off which makes a4 more tempting
as well because now you play a4 and then push up
on the b5 yeah here comes the king so this is my
first instinct and looks like he's going to end
up with two passers on the on the queen side now
if you take the king takes everybody and the rook
remains defending the a pawn i think he's winning
wow that would be quite the conversion for sauron
to to level the score in this match here
about 40 whoa and nvl just throws in the towel
says good play sir is good and then knight comes
in yeah e3 yeah that's also nice and g4 uh oh the
meeting that is on for perugia yeah one minute up
one night if i need to find it and then rook d1
wait all he needs is a draw but it's hard
to force it i know but here comes the people
oh my god no bishop by six is good you
should play six this should be five
oh okay this is checklisted to check knight
to check your check and you win three oh he
didn't see it natalie check was there oh
but he's found he's found nine of three
no but bishop to six and now another three
rookie two no bishop takes f3 then i mean you
doesn't help oh my god rouge is going to
send it over time no he's going to win it
he's going to win it yeah he wins it he wins
it oh god this is insane man this is insane
this is insane yeah that's still
still tonight what an incredible
heartbreak i have never seen a
match come down to this kind of